du jour ce sont les élèves de cette
école j'adore la façon dont ils
interpellent Emmanuel Macron c'est trop
choupi
[Musique]
Emmanuel Macron se réveille à Marseille
oui le président qui a passé une soirée
on va dire agité dans la cité de la
Busserine quartier Nord à Marseille et
ça rappelait le grand débat puisqu'il a
répondu aux questions et aux réflexions
aussi de 300 habitants sur l'insécurité
les règlements de comptes et les
lenteurs du plan Marseille en grand
lancés il y a 2 ans Hélène y était et
nous raconte pour RMC
on a
enfants plus les morts combien de
voitures brûlées combien de barbecues
humains nous sommes prisonniers à ciel
ouvert nous sommes des abonnés de
Netflix car nous vivons des scènes de
crimes dans nos quartiers directement
nous vivons une série télévisée moi je
prends pas les engueulades pour toutes
les décennies passées moi je partage
votre colère mais il y a un moment donné
cette colère il faut qu'on la
convertisse son projet sinon dès que je
suis parti on repart comme en 40 tout le
monde dit c'est pas moi c'est l'autre
c'est trop facile moi je vous promets je
fais le tour du Vieux Port ce soir avec
vous je vous trouve je suis sûr qu'il y
a 10 offres d'emploi
et depuis hier Rémi les réaction
proposée Macron ont été nombreuse
caricature Macron avant d'ajouter face
au mépris du peuple le seul chômeur que
l'on espère dans le pays c'est Emmanuel
Macron monsieur vierz vous avez une très
bonne idée ça fait un voyage journaliste
sur place pour savoir s'il y avait
vraiment du job et quels sont les
résultats de votre enquête alors
m'envoyer une journaliste Laetitia Alena
sur le Vieux-Port pendant une heure et
demie le président Macron parlait de
trouver 10 offres d'emploi rapidement on
en a trouvé 13 pour le coup donc il y a
des offres d'emploi clairement de
serveur de serveuse pour la plupart des
contrats de travail à 35 heures au SMIC
hôtelier soit 1966 euros brut par mois
poste de saisonnier qui pourrait se
prolonger s'il était se déroule bien
d'après les employeurs contactés les
employeurs potentiels qui admettent que
le travail est fatiguant qu'il peut être
éreintant en particulier l'été mais que
plus on bosse plus on gagne
des enfants choupi qui ont posé plein de
questions au monsieur de la République
française
[Musique]
[Rires]
3 2
on ouvre
[Musique]
oh
c'est pas facile
oh un premier vue c'est un bleu
la même couleur légèrement friable à la
découpe et pourtant c'est un fromage
sans lait c'est un fromage 100% végétal
une promesse osée que nous avons voulu
vérifier et honnêtement sans trop y
croire mais après quelques secondes
on est tout de suite pris par ce goût
qui est
identique
identique et qui même dans la
temporalité reste vraiment identique à
un bleu puisque vous devez encore sentir
un petit peu le goût piquant
pas facile vraiment pas facile parce que
il y a une odeur il y a une saveur très
particulière et très difficile à copier
mon burger c'est toujours bon
enfin qu'est-ce qu'il y a dedans
on connaît tous et il va falloir
réaliser ça donc je comprends pas le
délire une copie conforme réalisée par
la start-up américaine climax foods qui
utilise une intelligence artificielle
pour remplacer le lait par des végétaux
mais la recette est secrète une fois
qu'on a les caractéristiques du fromage
on va aller en fait rentrer ces
informations dans l'outil d'intelligence
artificielle qui va donc sonder en fait
dans sa base de données notre partenaire
à peu près 300 000 sources de végétaux
pour copier les propriétés que l'on
cible
je suis équipé enfin le bâtiment est
équipé d'une brosse pour pour le massage
des vaches les vaches ont la radio jour
et nuit
[Musique]
pas besoin de le poursuivre il suffit de
lui couper la route sauf que le
chauffard ne s'arrête pas
[Musique]
content de toi joint tard nos confrères
de BFM TV le patron de l'établissement
refuse de confirmer la présence de
Pierre palmat ce soir-là pourtant rien
interdit aux comédiens d'être en boîte
de nuit je pense que
il a assumé le fait le fait d'être en
boîte de nuit puisque il était certes
dans un lieu privatif dans les carrés
mais il ne se cachait pas il dansait il
était pas discret assez à l'aise ce yoga
bière consiste à allier et bah deux
passions deux activités relaxantes les
postures de yoga et la dégustation d'une
bonne bière alors attention je vois
votre enthousiasme il ne s'agit pas de
boire des peintres Cusset entre chaque
position on savoure une ou deux bières
maximum au cours d'une séance mais on
peut aussi se servir de son verre pour
adapter ses postures c'est ce que
propose du côté de Lille et de Roubaix
l'association Bir yoga France qui
propose régulièrement des séances en
plein air ou dans des brasseries moi ça
me choque pas qu'on ne picole pas dans
les stades
plus
on fait plus rien
picoler cloper c'est ça c'est en fait
on parlait en vacances bouffer de la
viande
parce que tout ça j'aime bien dis donc
c'est les cours collectifs ça dure une
heure pour 15 € bière compris alors
attention c'est interdit aux mineurs on
rappelle que l'alcool est évidemment à
consommer avec modération en revanche
les débutants sont les bienvenus j'avais
beaucoup de mal à me motiver je trouve
que ça passe une source de médiation si
on y va ensemble peut-être Manu et puis
après ça tu peux faire serveur sans
problème